In the SEAL teams,
there’s no training of how to
report your chief for war crimes.
There’s no way that I
could live with myself
had I not gone forward and
said what I saw.
I’m willing to put my life in
danger to get the job done.
It came over the radio, there
was a wounded prisoner.
Eddie said, nobody touch him,
he’s all mine.
Did you actually see it happen?
Yeah. I saw it happen.
This is the most disgraceful day
I've ever seen in my life.
I thought I was going to be in trouble
just for being there.
Did you ever intentionally
shoot any unarmed civilian?
No.
Did you ever try to kill an
unarmed teenage boy?
No.
Do you remember ever
shooting a little girl?
No.
It’s a very rare occurrence that
seals are going against one of their own.
There is a huge mistake going on here.
Everyone was covering their
tail from the top down.
The debate wasn’t,
did Eddie kill a prisoner?
The debate was, Eddie killed a
prisoner but is that okay?
They have no evidence, no proof.
Every man, woman and child
that came into his line of sight,
he tried to kill them.
No. That didn’t happen.
You’re making it up.
I hate Eddie but what
you’re doing is lying.
I should not be on trial
for murder. It is war.
I don’t think they
were prepared for...
this giant bombshell
in the court room.
I’m innocent.
I love you.
Hi sweetheart!
There’s a line in the sand now.
Unfortunately, the truth is not perfect.